shawn mendes is speaking out about his
worries and anxieties in a new social
media post admitting he constantly feels
like he's either flying or drowning yeah
sean began the candid note by writing
this sometimes i ask myself what it is
that i should be doing with my life and
what i always hear in return is to tell
the truth to be the truth i feel like
that's a hard thing to do though
yeah sean added i'm afraid that if
people know and see the truth they might
think less of me they might become bored
of me uh yeah in his moments of feeling
low sean says that he either puts on a
show or hides explaining the truth is
even with so much success i still find
it hard to feel like i'm not failing
hyper focused on what i don't have for
getting to see all that i do the truth
is i'm overwhelmed and overstimulated
and at just 23 years old sean questions
whether these feelings are just how
people in their 20s feel or if it's just
him he admits it's a struggle to not
care what anyone thinks and to be a
hundred percent his honest unique self
yeah now these despite the emotional
post sean does insist this the truth is
also that i'm okay i'm just trying to
tell and be the truth i like to think
that maybe
me saying this might resonate with some
people yeah so i guess fans were
concerned that you know he was being so
honest and want to make sure he was okay
that he then put a separate tweet where
he's reassuring his fans i'm honestly so
okay i just want to communicate with you
guys in a real honest way so i just
typed a big old note out for you lol
yeah it is and it's hard when you're 23
yeah and you go through oh this is you
the age that you go through all the big
life things for the first time right and
that's what you're going through most
people get to do it within their circle
of friends shawn mendes does it in front
of millions of people it's not an easy
thing and we've seen you know i've seen
in my lifetime people who were shawn
mendes before shawn mendes and they've
all gone through this sort of publicly
and it's and it's really and it's really
tough but when you are somebody like
shawn mendes um it's difficult to just
write that that stuff even if it is from
the heart and even if you genuinely are
okay to not freak people out it's true
right and that's the other thing that
the poor guy has to juggle yeah and i
think too when you're a superstar
sometimes i think there's guilt when you
say i'm not doing okay or i'm not
because so many people look up to him
and think you have everything you have
all this money of all this fandom so i
do think that some celebrities are a
little bit uh nervous at first
because they don't look like they're
complaining they don't want to uh seem
like they're not grateful or anything
like that i've seen some celebrities say
that but like he said if he's feeling
this way he's hoping that he can help
other people listen this is my first
reaction i'm not saying he's feeling
this way because of his breakup with
camila cabello but that was a huge
breakup yes it was a huge breakup and
then you've got to go on james corden
and talk about it like it's not a
natural thing
it's like he had his partner in crime
she understood the industry and
everything and i'm just saying it's
tough heartbreak's tough